samsung a sorti cette année deux galaxy
note galaxy note 20 galaxy note 20 ultra
de produits qui sont vraiment
intéressants je sais pas si vous
connaissez la gamme de samsung c'est la
gamme avec le stylet on lit dans le très
haut de gamme chez samsung mais ce qu'on
est vraiment chercher ici
et bien c'est tous les usages qu'on va
avoir avec le s pen le s pen
il est là il vous permet de venir
prendre des notes de venir dessiner
extrêmement facilement de mettre des
petits messages et de griffonner des
choses oui de manière artistique ou pas
en fonction de vos talents dans mon cas
c'est pas mais cette année samsung a
fait un choix qui est très particulier
et on retrouve notamment avec l'écart
entre ces deux produits
le galaxy note va ultras qui est le plus
haut de gamme est aussi le plus cher et
le galaxy note vague qui est le modèle
un peu standard sauf que à presque 1000
euros il y a plein de chasse qui vont il
ya aussi pas mal de choses qui vont pas
et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ce produit je
vous recommande pas et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi mais juste avant de
débuter cette vidéo je vous invite à
venir vous abonner pour tout savoir sur
l'actualité smartphone montre ordinateur
pc compagnie et tout ça est également
sur vous votre vie numérique les bons
usages tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
l'attaqué sur notre rapport aux objets
connectés vous invite donc à venir vous
abonner à notre petit bouton rouge qui
est situé juste là il est actionné la
cloche comme ça vous saurez tout des
puits prochaine vidéo sortira la
première chose à connaître c'est le prix
959 euros mais ya également une version
à 1059 euros c'est exactement ce prix
qui va orienter tout le reste de la
vidéo qui permettra de vous expliquer
pourquoi ce samsung galaxy note 20 à un
problème
faut vraiment garder ça en tête le prix
on est à quasiment mi euros on va
rebondir à 50 euros près on a 1000 euros
de contourner sur un smartphone un mille
euros on attend ce qui se fait mieux on
attend peut-être pas ce qu'on aura avec
le ultra c'est-à-dire l'excellence la
vega les smartphones aux alentours de
500 600 700 euros ils ont les mêmes
spécifications techniques que les
flagships à quelque chose près et qui
sont là pour un peu casser les pattes au
flagship là à 1000 euros on rigole
flagship devront s'attendre à voir se
calment mieux et ça me paraît
relativement normale sur le galaxy note
20 vous avez une version 4g qui est à
959 euros
vous avez une version 5 g à 1059 euros
tandis que son galaxy note 20 ultra vous
avez deux versions la première version
est à 1309 euros et la deuxième à 1409
euros on l'a donc une différence de 350
euros entre le moins cher des galaxy
note 20 est le moins cher des galaxy
note 20 ultra et 350 euros et ben ça
fait quand même un peu d'argent
et pour ses 350 euros on a quand même de
réelles différences entre ces deux
produits quels sont ces différences et
est-ce qu'elles vont jouer plutôt en
faveur du galaxy note 20 ou en faveur du
galaxy note the ultra dont vous avez vu
le titre de la vidéo vous explique vous
allez voir que j'ai plutôt en faveur du
galaxy note va ultra mais ce que vous ne
savez pas c'est pour quelles raisons
est-ce que je sois plus dubitatif devant
ce samsung galaxy note 20
la première raison c'est avec le choix
des matériaux dans les productions on a
la couleur mystique bronze qui est
vraiment très sympa mais la différence
d'un galaxy note 20 ultra ici vous avez
un dos en verre tandis qu'ici eh bien
vous avez un d'eau en plastique
alors certes un très jolie plastique du
plus bel effet mais on au toucher on
s'en rend compte déjà deux par la
température on a forcément un côté un
peu moins froid
fatalement c'est le matériau même si la
finition est bel et bien je me dis
qu'avoir un smartphone a quasiment 1000
euros avec un doigt en plastique et bah
ça me fait un peu râler quand même
deuxième point de différence et la
protection son galaxy note volts rage
d'avoir le dernier corning gorilla glass
tandis que sur le galaxy note 20 et bien
je vais voir le corning gorilla glass 5
qui aura des propriétés moins
protectrices que celui du galaxy note va
usera et une fois de plus a quasiment
1000 euros et bien ce à quoi faire râler
alors ça te serais le premier à vous
dire lorsque vous allez acheter un
smartphone à 1000 euros voir un petit
peu moins avoir un petit peu plus mais
peu importe lorsque vous allez acheter
un nouveau smartphone il faut le
protéger donc vous me direz ok on n'a
peut-être pas le dernier corning gorilla
glass au niveau du galaxy note 20 mais
je peux très bien mettre une protection
d'écran je dirais ok pourquoi pas ça se
tient vous me direz ok j'ai pas un dos
en verger inde ou en plastique mais de
toute façon tu dois déjà dit monsieur
drevet mettre une coque de protection
pour venir le protéger contre les chutes
donc d'une façon ou d'une autre
et bien c'est pas extrêmement grave
c'est vrai également mais malgré tout
dans l'esprit du consommateur
moi je suis consommateur je vais mettre
1000 euros à quelque chose près dans mon
nouveau smartphone et bien qu'il ait un
dos en plastique comme des smartphones à
200 ou 300 euros voyez ça fait quand
même un peu râler même si effectivement
et bien dans tous les cas je viens me
protéger mais au-delà de ça il ya un
autre point qui est extrêmement
importante et qui une fois de plus à 959
euros mais pas ce problème il ya deux
choses que vous trouverez pas sur le
samsung galaxy note 20 et que vous
retrouverez sur galaxy note 20 ultra ça
va être le menu résolution puisque ici
vous pouvez monter jusqu en wqs des plus
est ce que vous retrouverez également
ici c'est l'option fluidité des
mouvements puisque vous avez un écran
pourrait monter jusqu'à 125 d'istres
dans galaxy note 20 et bien ces menus
sont inexistantes pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que ce n'est pas du
tout possible vous avez ici un écran
full hd + et uniquement full hd + pas de
double des cages des plus et vous avez
ici à l'écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 60 r
oui uniquement de 60 hertz a quasiment
1000 euros et je remet en perspective
par rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver
déjà dans la gamme de samsung
si vous regardez les samsung galaxy s 20
de ce début d'année est bien vous
déploieront des choses très
intéressantes aujourd'hui moins cher
bien évidemment mais avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz et si vous
regardez à la concurrence des pour
trouver d excellent smartphone avec des
taux de rafraîchissement de 90 heures
c'est pas très cher et également 120
hertz et même de 100 m d'un milieu de
gamme dans la lidc pas de se dire on est
dans un milieu de gamme
on est pas du tout là dedans tout soit
en termes de photos de procession à tout
ça on est dans le haut de gamme dans le
très haut de gamme
oui sauf que pourquoi est-ce que ça me
soule qui nous sort un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme ne va pas jusqu'à
aller j'aurais dit 90 ans j'aurais pu
comprendre
il pourrait y avoir une logique mais un
écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 60 hertz aujourd'hui quasiment 1000
euros me 2020 sur un flagship je
comprends pas alors à quoi ça veut pas
dire que vous allez forcément utiliser
du 120 hertz peut-être que vous n'allez
jamais l'utiliser peut-être que ça ne
vous intéressera pas oui effectivement
le 100 m ça va consommer davantage au
niveau de batterie l'autonomie va
diminuer drastiquement je suis d'accord
avec tout ça sauf que une fois de plus
je me repositionne dans un esprit
d'achat je veux aujourd'hui acheter un
excellent smartphone avec les meilleurs
techno sont quand même mettre 1000 euros
quasiment 1000 euros et même si je passe
pas mon opérateur avec un forfait un peu
plus cher dans tous les cas je vais le
payer donc pourquoi est ce que j'irai
prendre un smartphone qui n'a pas les
meilleurs techno à quelque chose près ni
2020 il ya un truc qui cloche quand même
bon j'ai également une différence de
techno super amoled vs dynamique amoled
j'ai une différence de taille 6 7 pouces
des 6 8 9 pouces ça ça me paraît
complètement normal j'ai une différence
également qui s'est tu juste là qui sera
du point de détail c'est la taille du
poinçon elle est beaucoup plus grande
sur galaxy note 20 que son galaxy note
20 ultra sur le galaxy note veut ultra
j'ai un écran qui est incurvé ce qui va
vraiment venir apporter beaucoup plus
d'immersion et qui donne un côté
beaucoup plus premium à mon smartphone
tandis qu'ici j'ai un écran plat ce qui
est plutôt très classique pouvez
retrouver dans les smartphone milieu de
gamme chez samsung
et ça c'est vrai que c'est aussi
relativement dommage votre smartphone
vous allez passer beaucoup de temps les
yeux rivés sur lui donc le fait de ne
pas avoir la meilleure expérience qu'à
une des meilleures expériences avec le
côté incurvé plat ça fait un peu râler
surtout ce taux de rafraîchissement
c'est extrêmement important je vous le
redis encore en perspective 959 euros
959 euros c'est dommage effectivement sa
porte des usages en termes de fluidité
mais en termes de marketing c'est un
argument qui est extrêmement important
et qui est vraiment mis en avant par
samsung et par les concurrents donc
quand on sait que c'est un argument qui
va faire vendre notamment pour les
technophiles et ce produit-là s'adresse
aussi et beaucoup aux technophiles ne
pas pouvoir mettre en avant cet argument
est risqué de faire retoquer juste non
avec un écran 30 r ce n'est pas
compréhensible
autre différence au niveau du stockage
sur galaxy note 20 vous avez 256 gigant
non extensible offre aux galaxy note va
utre à vous avez soit 250 gigas soit 512
dans les deux cas extensible jusqu'à 1
tera grâce à une carte microsd
ça peut paraître un trophée ctive mans
un point de détail d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui on est quasiment tous
dans le club
mais malgré tout une fois de plus sur un
smartphone a quasiment 1000 euros vous
dites que vous ne pouvez pas venir
augmenter votre capacité de stockage bon
après je suis d'accord devant 56 giga de
stockage déjà vous avez de quoi faire
tout si vous stockez vos photos dans le
club on également différence au niveau
de la batterie kapil 300 millions paiera
pour le galaxy note 20 contre 4500
millions terreur pour galaxy note 20
ultra mais la différence au niveau
d'autonomie
ça se tient à pas grand chose mais
qu'est ce qui fait l'adn de la gamme
notes et bien joué il donne dans le
mille cesson espen et le s pen il ya une
différence sur le galaxy note 20 vous
avez un style etc et une latence de 26
millisecondes tandis que sur le galaxy
note 20 ultra vous avez un style etc et
une latence de neuf millisecondes et
cette différence elle fait toute la
différence en termes de ciblage pourquoi
déjà il faut savoir que sont samsung
galaxy note 10 de l'année dernière vous
avez une latence de 40 2 millisecondes
donc c'est vrai qu'entre 40 2
millisecondes et 26 millisecondes il ya
une amélioration c'est certain mais on
voit qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent faire
beaucoup mieux avec une latence de 9000
seconde qui donne un aspect extrêmement
naturel comme si vous griffonné sur une
feuille de papier
alors vous allez vous dire j'ai 26
millisecondes g9 millisecondes qu'elle
vaille vraiment la différence et la
différence en fait c'est le ciblage vous
à l'établé avec le samsung galaxy note
20 ultra avec la 39 millisecondes des
gens qui ont un usage extrêmement précis
qui sont vraiment des connaisseurs
probablement des infographistes des
illustrateurs des dessinateurs à tous
qui finit en tort à quelque chose près
avec le galaxy note 20 on va s'adresser
à un public plus amateur - pro des
personnes qui veulent découvrir qui
veulent commencer à utiliser un stylet
n'est qui le fait de ne pas avoir la
latence la plus fun
pas poser problème une fois de plus je
reprends mon raisonnement j'en prends ma
logique en disant j'ai à peu près une
enveloppe de 1000 euros à mettre dans un
smartphone je suis d'accord entre 959
euros
émile 359 euros vous accable 350 euros
d'écart ce qui représente beaucoup
d'argent mais puisque l' usage principal
est la raison pour laquelle on va les
acheter
c'est cette petite bête là pourquoi tout
de suite le palet sur ce qu'il fait
mieux lorsqu'on à 1000 euros à poser sur
la table
est ce que ces quelques millisecondes de
latence justifie 350 euros d'écart pour
les personnes qui ont un usage pro je
pense que oui pour ceux qui n'ont pas un
usage pro je pense que non d'ailleurs
dit moi vous c'est votre cas en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous pensez que
ces quelques millisecondes de latence
vont justifier la différence de prix
n'ont pas elles seules parce qu'on l'a
vu il ya plein d'autres choses qui le
justifie mais est-ce que vous vu que le
style et c'est quand même l'usagé
principal est ce que vous pourriez
mettre 350 euros de plus pour réduire de
quelques millisecondes à latence marquer
le coup en bas ça ça m'intéresse
et on également une différence
importante au niveau de la photo puisque
son grand angle on a un capteur de 12
mégapixels contre 108 mégapixels ce
galaxy note 20 ultra etc sur le
téléobjectif avoir 64 mégapixels avec un
zoom libre il faut trois aspects du mfa
tronçon le galaxy note 20 qui situent
juste ici c'est le galaxy note veulent
trash voire 12 mégapixels avec un zoom
optique x 5 et aspect zoom x 50 le reste
de la configuration est sensiblement
similaire bien con d un laser sur le
galaxy note 20 ultra et non pas sur
l'autre notamment pour le mode portrait
pour les faits évoqués mais si on oublie
un peu côté configuration était bien le
galaxy note vince vous allez faire des
photos d'excellente qualité
de jour comme de nuit ça marche très
très bien vous ne serez pas des chutes
donc en termes de photos il justifie son
prix il ya aussi une petite différence
au niveau d'une techno qui s'appelle
poynton cher qui sera disponible
uniquement sur le samsung galaxy note 20
ultra en termes de performances dans les
deux cas on à l'exil en 1990 ce qui
fonctionnera bien la différence va se
faire au niveau de la ram puisque sur le
galaxy note 20 version 4g vous avez 8
gigas de ram et sur la version 5 g 12
giga de ram connaissent que ce soit
galaxy note 20 ultra vous avez 12 il ya
drame de partout donc plus de fluidité
et justement et ça c'est intéressant
parce que si vous voulez sur votre
galaxy note 20 et bien voir 12 giga de
ram prendre un maximum de fluidité comme
si notre vie ultra eh bien voyez que en
termes de tarifs pour passer de 9 159
euros à 1059 euros dont vous vous
rapprochez tous nous pas tout doucement
tout doucement doucement du tarif des
1300 9 euros on n'y est pas encore il ya
toujours un delta mais tout de même on
s'en rapproche donc est ce que cette
config 5 g est intéressante aujourd'hui
ça dépend parce que la 5g va arriver
les années à venir tout doucement dre
commencé à la voir arriver en fin 2020
voire 2020 en tout cas en france par
uniquement de la france si vous êtes en
suisse vous l'avez déjà il ya deux pays
où elle est là et d'autres pays n est
pas encore là où elle n'est pas prête à
arriver donc ça dépend même de vous en
france ou en suisse ou dans le pays dans
lequel vous vous situez si la 5g là est
ce qu'elle est là dans votre région oui
ou non
donc je dérive on l'aperçoit 5 j'ai tout
de suite pourquoi pas si on se projette
pour un smartphone qu'on regarde deux
trois ans et que dès que la 5g arrivera
on veut la prendre
sinon la version 4g pour l'instant fera
la sphère bon après c'est un smartphone
que j'aime bien il haldex sans fil il
est rapide il est performant vous avez
un capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique il est verrouillé
extrêmement rapidement il y a les
réactions si vous souhaitez les utilisez
vous avez un nouveau mode vidéo pro
qu'on retrouve dans les deux modèles qui
fonctionne parfaitement bien il a du
wifi si c'est certifié il pèse 68 mais
malgré tout vous voyez la question se
pose est la question
la vraie question à se poser là dessus
ce n'est pas la question des 8 vs 12 il
ya drame la question à se poser c'est
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'un style
est ce qu'il vous faut un smartphone
avec un style et si oui pour quel usage
cela permet déjà de vous orienter entre
une config ou l'autre et si visage du s
pen sur ce smartphone là n'est pas je
dirais un usage primordial eh bien je ne
suis pas nécessairement sûr que c'est le
galaxy note 20 qu'il vous faut si vous
voulez un excellent smartphone de
samsung un très bon flagship vous avez
les smartphones du début d'année qui ont
le même processeur qui vont très bien
avec les mêmes techno et que vous
trouvez aujourd'hui moins cher vous
pouvez même trouver un samsung galaxy s
20 ultras qui est le top en photo
aujourd'hui c'est ça me sauve tout temps
le travail plus loin en photo que le
galaxy note va ultra et vous trouverez
beaucoup moins cher en reconditionnés
donc la question à se poser c'est le s
pen est ce qu'il vous faut réellement en
espèces est-ce que vous en avez
réellement en usage si c'est un usage
plutôt pro et vous voulez vraiment ce
qui se fait de mieux aller là dessus
j'ai toujours une question de finances
jeu le 7 mai 300 euros ça reste quand
même beaucoup d'argent le galaxy note 20
il est pas mal
il a des techniques qui sont
intéressantes il marche bien il est très
actuel mais voyez mettre quasiment 1000
euros avec un smartphone avec un doux en
plastique avec un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 60 hertz avec un
écran place pour autant c'est que les
écrans c'est la valeur ajoutée de
samsung quoi c'est une belle valeur
ajoutée de samsung
tout ça mis bout à bout mis bout-à-bout
fait que ce smartphone là aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible de venir vous le
conseillez peut-être qu'il faut
repositionner la gamme
non pas sur l'ultra mais sur se produire
il aurait peut-être fallu un galaxy note
20 ultra comme oh là là un galaxy note
20 avec un écran taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 hertz ou de 120
hertz avec un dos en verre mais je pense
surtout que un smartphone comme ça avec
un écran tôt sans terre et un dos en
plastique
on pourrait l'entendre avec un samsung
galaxy note 20 lights et non pas qu'un
samsung galaxy note vous me direz vous
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec mon analyse est ce que
vous le prouve intéressant est ce que
vous l'avez acheté ce que vous pourriez
l'acheter si vous l'avez acheté pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes positionner dessus
qu'est ce que vous pensez de son
positionnement tarifaire mark et moi
tout ça en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on reste connectés parce qu'il ya
plein de choses à se dire
bien évidemment sur samsung sur plein
d'autres marques plein de nouveautés
smartphone et une fois de plus plein
sahara compter sur vous votre vie
numérique et je pense qu'on ne va pas
être déçu
sur ce je vous embrasse nous avons
beaucoup d'amour et à très vite
caoutchouc